plus que quelques jours peut être
quelques semaines et les sénateurs
rendront enfin leurs conclusions dans la
tentaculaire affaire benalla point de
départ pour la commission denquête les
violences de la place de la contrescarpe
le monde révèle le 18 juillet l'identité
d'alexandre benalla s'ensuivront 29
auditions dont celle de l'ancien chargé
de mission avec un constat qui apparaît
au fil des témoignages
alexandre benalla a désorganisé les
services de l'état en ce qui concerne
monsieur ben alla je ne suis toujours
pas convaincu qu'il n'exerçait pas la
fonction de garde du corps
comment expliquer autrement le port
d'armes
mais en décembre la sphère est relancée
lors d'une visite des manuels maquereau
au tchad
on apprend qu alexandre benalla à
continuer à utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques alors qu'il n'était plus
salariée de l'elysée
les sénateurs décide alors d'organiser
cinq nouvelles auditions
quand il va voir le prés le frère du
président du tchad qui a un rôle
imminent matière de sécurité et
d'importation d'armes au tchad et qu'il
le fait avec un passeport officiel on
peut quand même s'interroger sur le rôle
réel de monsieur benalla dans une
diplomatie parallèle aux soupçons de
diplomatie parallèle s'ajoutent ensuite
le volet sur les contrats russe il
aurait été négocié pour l'un d'entre eux
au moins alors qu'alexandre benalla
était encore salarié de l'elysée je
voulais vous demander si vous
connaissiez monsieur iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne nous à
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
une réponse prononcée alors qu'alexandre
benalla était sous serment
de nombreux sénateurs le suspecte alors
d'avoir commis un parjure
il nous a menti en tout cas la
commission en décidera mais
manifestement il nous a menti et
sûrement pas qu'une seule fois donc on
va prospecter en la matière si nous
sommes intimement convaincus qu'il ya eu
mensonge
en tout cas ça c'est mon intime
conviction personnelle nous devons
demander à la justice de sanctionner mme
dubé dallas sur tous ses volets de la
sphère benalla les conclusions les
sénateurs sont donc très attendus